my name is Jacob Kabbalah I teach
history and digital studies at Davidson
College and today I'll be speaking about
using computational methods of
hierarchical clustering and machine
learning to predict and identify unknown
authors in corpora of medieval Latin
texts
so I will talk today about a an
application of computational methods to
a problem in the humanities and the
problem the humanities is a very old one
it's about authorship attribution and I
am this background I'm a medievalist by
training and so I'll be talking about
tax written in Latin so problem is that
we have lots and lots of texts that come
to the Middle Ages in a variety of
languages a Latin Greek Old English
whole Church Slavonic and for thousands
of these texts we simply don't know who
wrote them and the question then is can
computational methods help us determine
who wrote texts the case study now see
that male make is bigger the case study
I want to talk to you today about is
that of the so-called galas anonymous
and the monk of lido the monk of Lido is
the name that we have given to a text
composed in the early 12th century
called the translation of st. Nicholas
to Venice it's about 12,000 words long I
was written most likely between 1102
1108 in Venice the second text Gallus
anonymous who wrote the first chronicle
of the Polish history the deeds of the
princess of the poles the texts about
twice as long written about five to ten
years later in Poland and I've given you
a map here just to give you an
orientation of place yellow dots
correspond to the life as we know it of
Calais red dots correspond to the life
as we know it of it the monk and a
question is and I can get into this
later if you're interested are these two
anonymous authors or one on the same
author and there have been there's been
a long debate in the field of history
that saying yes they are no they're not
well so what is the case I have been
working on an authorship attribution a
package to work on problems such as this
so we need to put together some corpora
of texts that are similar within which
we can compare
the two so luckily for us medievalist we
have lots and lots of texts from the
Middle Ages available in digital form so
it's a matter of downloading those and I
want to show you the details of how I
import them and so on but I'll just show
you the their makeup here we have a make
this smaller
the first corpus and I'm testing the
similarity between these two texts the
first in four different corpora the
first corpus contains 39 texts and here
is a mixture of different genres so we
have theological works we have
historical works we have letters all
different kinds of genre and all
different kinds of word lengths so the
longest text in this corpus here is over
150,000 words the shortest one is about
10,000 words or so second text can is is
a second corpus contains all of these 39
texts but broken up into roughly equal
length segments an idea there is to see
does there you see the so here we have
the text and the corpus with with its
length and words idea there is the test
does the length of a text to make a
difference in accuracy of attribution
third corpus here I've it's a taken the
this this corporate what I'm calling
corpus for and I apologize for the for
the numbering system but it's the way
I've been doing the research and it's
just too complicated for me to change it
corpus 3 contains it's a subset of
corpus form where I have controlled for
genre so it's a smaller corpus about 69
texts total here we have roughly same
lengths same genre but I call this
unbalanced one because some of the
authors for example William of
Malmesbury
has many representative texts in here
whereas others have just a couple
representative texts and to solve for
that problem that's a problem that comes
up in machine learning applications and
I'll talk about that in a second this is
a corpus six a subset of the final one
in which I have balanced out the author
classes so here every author has about
two to three texts representative texts
about 12,000 words long let's see if
this works any better okay so there you
see the the four different corpora that
I'm interested in and these are all
taken from eleventh and twelfth century
Latin prose next step then is to extract
features and it's a translate all of
these texts into some kind of numerical
form which we can then compare
mathematically for this experiment I've
just taken most frequent words so here
and this is a function that I've
included in this package I'm building I
calculates say the 250 most frequent
words in eaten an entire corpus so if
you do that for the in the third corpus
just to give you a sense you get a list
250 words these are also called function
words the ands the in deeds their fors
and whatnot those words that we use most
frequently but we use without really
thinking about them and they're they
turn out to be the some of the best
indicators of of authorship next up then
is for every text in a corpus to
calculate the frequencies of occurrence
of those 250 most frequent words in each
member text and what that produces then
is something like this where here we
have a every text you see on the left
here corresponds to a long list of
frequencies and these are the giving you
the words at these are the frequencies
of this particular word in this
particular text the next step and final
step is to prepare for cross validation
and this is because it turns out that
you can check your work and also even
improve accuracy if you repeat the same
process not for entire text segments but
if you first sample out a random number
of words
Tech segment and then calculate the
frequencies of the most frequent words
in those random so-called bags of words
and here I've done that four bags of
words taken from each text the five
thousand long so five thousand word bags
taken from each text then when we
calculate the frequencies of those most
frequent words we get something similar
and here so for every corpus we have 10
different samplings and this is some
doing this in order to validate the
results we get later on and again each
one of these 250 frequencies long ok
then their turn out there are two broad
approaches to dealing with this so now
we have lots of data in numerical form
and we can do something with it two
broad approaches or distance measures
and machine learning approaches distance
methods first we can import the
hierarchical clustering package that
comes with Mathematica and then
visualize the distances between our
texts and in a dendrogram the way these
work so here for example I'm this is
just a little helper function I wrote
but we're looking at distances in corpus
six as determined by whichever one of
these distance measures we select
Euclidean distance squared Euclidean
chessboard Manhattan and so on all the
way down to break artists distance and
these are eight distance measures for
numerical data that come with
Mathematica and so we can see you can
see two things on this dendrogram one is
that the closer to the right of the plot
two texts are connected that means the
closer they are in the lower the
distance the smaller the distance
between them you can also see that based
on how different texts the
how close they are on this y-axis and
indeed if you take a look you see that
texts written by the same author and the
author name you see as the first element
of the label there do tend the cluster
together so these three segments written
by Luke brand cluster these three
segments written by mallet are a cluster
etc the two halves of Gallus and the one
half and and the in a segment of the
monk also cluster together here and in
fact some of the distance measures
cluster or indicate that the distance
between the monks texts and the first
half of galaxy's texts is smaller than
the distance between the two halves of
Gallus so that's interesting if you do
that though for a big corpora it becomes
difficult to so this is the fourth
corpus we have a hundred and sixteen
text segments you see the same pattern
authors cluster together but it's
difficult to interpret this so is there
a way of measuring accuracy then and for
accuracy with this method I simply mean
how effective are the eight distance
measures at placing a text in a corpus
as closest to another text written by
the same author that we definitely know
was written by the same author when we
do this we get neat results so this is
just a tabulation of these results for
you in corpus 0 which is again varying
lengths and varying genres we get the
highest accuracy rate of about 77% so
out of 27 possible accurate attributions
there 21 this goes up in the other
corpora to about 98% in corpus 3 same
98% best-performing 1 corpus 4 and 100%
accuracy for these within this corpus of
course
corpus six a couple things to see here
to salta all together the chess board
distance is uniformly it appears
ill-suited to determining authorship the
best performing distance across the
board here seems to be the break curtis
distance and manhattan distance which
are mathematically related
cross-validation running the same doing
the same process on each of those bags
of words taken within every corpus
confirms these results and it doesn't
seem to be a fluke so if if especially
within corpus for notice also the
difference between zero and four zero
and four contain the same words they
just corpus zero contains these texts
that are some are 150,000 words long
some are 10,000 words long corpus 4
contains those same text but split up
into segments notice what happens to the
accuracy there it shoots up to the about
ninety seven point four point five
percent their meaning genre of written
work is not a hindrance to determining
or it's a attributing authorship within
the corpora the length of the text is so
that's an interesting to me result so
this works pretty well how would do
Galison and monk do here well within
corpus zero the least well performing
corpus the text closest to monk
according to seven out of the eight
measures is indeed Gallus the one
outlier is the poorly performing chess
board distance and in the reverse the
text closest to Galus is amongst text
again with a couple exceptions here this
is confirmed also in in the other
corpora so we always have we have a
pretty pretty clear signal here at least
within the corpora
that these two texts are really close to
each other the subsampling also confirms
this to be the case so out of ten
sub-samples in corpus zero the
best-performing distances without fail
attribute Gallus the monk and so on here
we see also 10 of 10 9 out of 10 10 out
of 10 10 out of 10 I will let's see I
will skip this now and move to the
machine learning as an approach so this
is that's one approach distances the
other approach is machine learning and I
learned quite a lot today earlier in the
afternoon about the deeper possibilities
of machine of mathematical Michigan
learning so this may seem a little
rudimentary but it's so incredibly
effective the basic idea here is we
treat authors as classes and we treat
the frequency lists as items that we can
assign to a class and thereby using the
classify function to train a classifier
the one method involved here is known as
leave one out cross validation which
I'll just play this out so it's the the
process takes out say the very first one
of these frequency lists builds a
classifier with the remaining frequency
lists in which this frequency list will
be attributed to assign the class cosmas
this one to class cosmas this one's a
classic Albert etc all the way down the
line then it takes out the second one
and builds a class of and trains a and
built a tree it classifies the machine
using the training set consisting of all
the remaining ones etc all the way down
the line so here we have 69 excuse me 39
different texts so we'll get 39
different training sets the results of
this
also pretty good here we see what
happens two full texts so and here's a
corpus for what is the first closest
author class to which this text belongs
and the method I've been using here is
logistic regression which proves to be
very robust for multi class problems
like Oh such as this one where it's not
just is an author is not another but
there are many different types of
possible many different classes of
authors so if you looked down the line
here sure by-and-large
authors text could attribute it to the
proper the correct author class all the
way down the line with a few exceptions
here our Monk gets attributed to class
galas with 80% or so certainty the
results are a bit more easily digestible
if we look at the cross validation
results and so here I wonder if I can
make this smaller yes
so here for every one of these bags of
words and repeated this method and the
the ss1 ss2 as a subsample one subsample
two and you see that pad of ten times
this particular text was attributed to
the core to the correct after class then
I have ten times and you can see on the
right this particular tax was tribute
the right after class and so on the ones
where we see absolutely no correct
attributions are by and large the ones
where we would expect no correct
attributions because if you notice if we
take out this text from the corpus then
there is no remaining text belonging to
the author class cosmas with which in
the training set so once if we pass in
an unknown author
there simply is no possibility of
correct attribution the results get much
better again in the later corpora so and
you can see that here so how exactly
effective is this method it turns out it
is just as effective on full text as the
distance method and it's so more
effective than the distance method when
you do bags of words so even within
Corpus 0 the the wildest and corpus of
the four we get eighty-three percent
accuracy of attribution you using the
bags of word method finally how what is
it where does this what does this give
us as results for the the case study
that that I've proposed monk the the
monks text does seem to be classified as
Gallus for four out of four times and
without fail also during in the
subsampling conclusions it seems that
distance measures and machine learning
algorithms and in particular the break
heard his distance and logistic
regression proved remarkably good at
identifying Latin authors on the basis
of most frequent word frequencies I
mentioned the second conclusion earlier
which is that text length within a
corpus uniform text length is a much
much more important for accurate
attribution than a genre as long as you
have equal text length in a corpus
you'll get good results if you have
mixed genre that doesn't that doesn't
make a difference there seems little
doubt based on this too that Gallus and
monk are one of the same again however
in the context the corpora that I've
assembled so the next steps
of many but one of the major next steps
would be to broaden and in Lardon to
make the corpus much bigger see what
kind of results we get when we take say
if it's possible all texts all Latin
texts that survived from the early 12th
century or first half a 12th century you
can also try different parameters so
different sizes of bags of words for
subsampling different numbers of most
frequent words we can also try a whole
series of different features altogether
so instead of counting words count
character sequences character engrams
parts of speech syntactical features and
so on so thanks for listening
[Applause]